c'est devenu un passage obligé
chaque premier ministre du québec de
passage à paris prévoit désormais une
rencontre avec dany laferrière premier
écrivain québécois membre de l'académie
française
un peu comme monument qu'on visite un
monument littéraire
un exercice auquel auteurs se prête de
bonne grâce de la politique avant de se
hisser jusqu'à son siège de premier
ministre françois legault était un homme
d'affaires
un passé qui marque son action politique
comme il se plaît à le répéter ici
le chef de la caq a prévu rencontrer à
paris les plus grands patrons français
pour les inciter à investir davantage
dans la province nouveau bond des
échanges commerciaux entre la france et
le québec sont au coeur de sa visite il
le répète sur toutes les tribunes 5
milliards sait rien on pourrait doubler
ce montant là assez facilement
selon lui l'accord économique et
commercial entre l'europe et le canada
est une occasion en or à saisir mais ses
homologues français il le sait sont
actuellement bien d'autres soucis
empêtré dans une crise sociale majeure
celle des gilet jaune ce premies bonjour
janvier
en entrevue à radio canada françois
legault dit qu'il faut savoir tirer les
enseignements de ce soulèvement
populaire
la leçon qu'on peut tirer de ce qui se
passe à clichy les jambes c'est qu'on
voit qu'une limite à ce que le
contribuable peut payer
selon lui la marge de manoeuvre des
politiciens aujourd'hui et metz car le
populisme y est
il faut être prudent de parler c'est un
certain populisme aller chercher l'appui
des personnes qui sont un peu choqué de
voir une société où ils n'ont pas
toujours leur place
donc c'est un défi pour tout le monde
c'est un défi au québec demain françois
legault doit rencontrer le président
français emmanuel macron et le premier
ministre edouard philippe
au menu des discussions les questions
d'immigration de formation de haute
technologie d'intelligence artificielle
et bien sûr des investissements et des
échanges commerciaux
et si jean françois bélanger
radio-canada paris